Speaker 1: President Joe Biden is under
fire because he said that the so-called
MAGA crowd is the most extreme political group
in U.S. history. And he is exactly right. And
I know many of you will say. But, sir, what
about the KKK or what about the. I am going to
get to that in a moment. And let's take a look
first at what Joe Biden said, Axios reporting.
President Biden on Wednesday said the MAGA crowd
is really the most extreme political organization
that's existed in American history. While
speculating on how conservative state legislatures
could respond to a potential Supreme Court ruling
that would drastically curtail abortion access,
this was when Biden was taking questions
from reporters about the leaked draft opinion
of the Roe v Wade decision. Let's
take a look at this video and what
Joe Biden said, and then we will discuss.
Speaker 3: What happens if you have stage changed
the law saying that that that children who are
LGBTQ can't be in classrooms with other children.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Is that is that logic under
the way the decision is written? What are the next
things that are going to be attacked? Because this
MAGA crowd is really the most extreme political
organization that's existed in American history
in recent American history.
Speaker 1: Okay. So he clarifies
and says in recent American history. Now,
I actually think the addition of recent
is important. And I'll get back to what I think
of when he says recent. But let's talk about it,
because Joe Biden is correct. I've
been saying this for a long time
and I'm glad that he is saying it. So
let's take the obvious counterpoint. Well,
what about a group like the KKK, the Ku Klux Klan,
for example? The KKK was not an actual prominent
political group in recent American history. The
KKK, if you've looked at KKK history, there's
sort of like a different they call them like
the first Klan, the second Klan, the third Klan.
The estimated peak of the second Klan was in the
mid 1920s. And it's estimated that at that point
the KKK had 3 to 6 million members, only some
of whom actually voted. So as a political
first of all, you could say it's not even really
a political movement, but let's let's give that
say it is even as a political movement. There
were 74 million people who voted for President
Trump in 2020. And a ton of them are part of what
we would call the MAGA movement. Not all. I mean,
there are some Republicans there who just didn't
like Hillary and they didn't like Biden. But
we're talking about a group that, at least
at the top line is 74 million people.
The peak of the second Klan was 3 to 6 million
in the 1920s. More recently, the Anti-Defamation
League estimates that there is about 30 active
KKK groups with like 3 to 6000 members. So
statistically, I mean, Joe Biden is correct.
This this is the most extreme political group.
And the only confusion to me is why did Biden
think or say that he could, quote, work with
them as he did during the campaign? Maybe he just
felt he had to say it. And I would understand that
it may not be well received. If you're Biden and
you know, you can't work with these lunatics, if
during your campaign you go, I don't even intend
to listen to these people, it probably doesn't
play well. So I understand that. Now, let's
talk about the addition of in recent history.
If we think back to the Civil War and many of you
will immediately know where I'm going with this.
The Confederacy. Do you have to go back to
the Confederacy to find a political movement
as extreme as MAGA? I think maybe you do.
And so that's why the kind of addition of
recent history by Joe Biden maybe clarifies or
even puts puts a better kind of point on it. The
question I am concerned with, and I know many of
you are concerned with because you email me about
it all the time, is, okay, how do we deprogram
them? How do we de-radicalize millions of people?
And we've talked about techniques before.
We've talked about empathy, listening,
building relationships. This takes a really
long time. It's got to be done basically one
on one or maybe one on two or something like
that. But in order to really de-radicalize MAGA
and by de-radicalize I mean they're
only held together by their radicalism.
So when we say de-radicalize, we're probably
talking about an evaporation of the movement.
You have to deal with Steve Bannon, Roger Stone,
Trump himself, Michael Flynn, Fox News, Infowars,
Newsmax, Oann, Dan Bongino, Ben SHAPIRO,
Breitbart. All of these different things
as well as the social media algorithms
that amplify the stuff that they post.
If you don't deal with that, you're
not going to fix it. The problem is,
I don't think we can just start de-platforming. I
just don't think so. Not only does it go against
some of our principles importantly, but it
would cause a backlash. It would potentially
cause a significant increase of physical
violence from the Devoted magazine. So,
you know, don't get me wrong. Everybody who's
committed a crime. January six, Trump, riots,
terroristic threats, all these different
things. Charge them, throw the book at them,
etc.. But just like a mass de-platforming
movement isn't in line with leftist values
and it also wouldn't be effective. So I don't
think that's that's the answer. And then that
leaves us with the question of, well, what is the
answer? And we don't know. We don't always have
the answers. And the reason I've been interviewing
cult experts, conspiracy experts, etc., is to try
to get ideas about what might actually work.
Always open to hearing ideas from you as well